[Applaudissements]
quand j'avais 4 ans je voulais être
pâtissier après à cinq ans c'était plus
le salé donc cuisinier à 7 ans je
voulais être archéologue et puis à
jurassic park les dinosaures donc un peu
après c'était plutôt paléontologue à 12
ans comme la plupart des garçons dans
les années 90 qui découvre l
informatique j'ai voulu d'ingénieur en
informatique puis à 14 15 ans et l
architecture qui m'intéressait je suis
arrivé au lycée
effectivement je ne savais pas encore
vraiment ce que je voulais faire donc on
a mis en filière scientifique comme les
élèves à peu près brillant à l'époque
c'était s j'avais un parcours artistique
depuis tout petit le conservatoire une
famille de musiciens
et puis mes premiers groupes de rock
dans le garage à reprendre du led
zeppelin et donc j'ai choisi à cette
époque là que je voudrais un ingénieur
du son mes années lycée c'était des
années vraiment vraiment sympa du bon
temps avec les copains avec les copines
et beaucoup de choses mais en dehors des
bancs de l'école du lycée qui font que
j'ai obtenu mon bac s avec mention
mais surtout la mention dilettante gâche
son potentiel
sam est un dossier scolaire un peu
marqué d'appréciation de profs un peu
énervé par votre comportement qui se
fait un peu trop confiance qui finit par
avoir son bac mais sans trop d'efforts
et la finalité c'est que j'avais postulé
dans à peu près toutes les filières
possibles pour être ingénieur du son en
france et que jean nuit aucune
donc je me suis retrouvé à la fac g
ça arrive on peut s'en sortir
j'ai choisi musicologie musicologie
parce que ça me paraissait logique après
cette passion de la musique depuis tout
petit je me disais que ça me laisser le
temps de voir j'avais peur quand même de
cette liberté de l'université après des
années lycée un petit peu un petit peu
trop festive et au final ça m'a pris
j'ai gagné en maturité et ça m'a permis
de me concentrer vraiment sur mes études
et j'ai beaucoup aimé les enseignements
l'érudition et j'ai obtenu rapidement de
très bons résultats et ça m'a permis de
continuer à faire plein de choses en
dehors d'avoir un premier job j'étais
pions dans un collège puis ensuite j'ai
enseigné dans une école de musique j'ai
fait mes armes avec des jeunes avec les
élèves et la licence s'est passé comme
ça de façon très sympathique j'étais à
rouen en province très épanouissante
il a fallu faire un choix il a fallu
choisir
alors quand vous faites musicologie en a
pas beaucoup vous aviez la recherche des
manuscrits poussière d'un compositeur
obscur de l'époque baroque très peu
connu qu'il fallait remettre au goût du
jour
ou alors un choix concrets qui était
celui de passer le capes pour être
professeur d'éducation musicale et chant
choral
ça vous rappelle des souvenirs la flûte
à bec le collège tout ça j'ai passé le
concours tout le monde disait il y avait
90 places sur toute la france donc
c'était un concours difficile et on
disait bras c'est trop dur fait autre
chose
j'aimais bien cette idée de challenge
donc je vais passer et puis je les ai
eus je me suis retrouvé donc à 22 ans
fonctionnaire professeurs de l'éducation
nationale donc c'est une carrière qui
commence et quand même dans la musique
mais un petit peu plus loin des studios
d'enregistrement et de la scène ça s'est
un peu gâté quand j'ai pris mon premier
post de taizé d'air en seine saint denis
alors taisez d'air ça veut dire
titulaire en zone de remplacement en
langage non académique ça veut dire
bouche trou dans des endroits où il
manque du temps des heures et puis vous
allez un petit peu comme ça de façon
très inconfortable
essayez d'enseigner dans différents
collèges sur vos premiers sur vos
premières années de fonction c'est à
dire celle où vous êtes le moins bon et
donc je me retrouve à paris dans
l'académie de créteil
tout le monde te diras tu vas voir paris
c'est génial la vie culturelle ouverture
sur le monde
moi la seule chose que je vois à ce
moment là c'est d'arriver dans un
appartement qui fait la taille de mon
ancien salon au cinquième étage sans
ascenseur et puis tous les matins ses
lignes aux douze conventions jusqu'à
mont parnès ligne 4 gare du nord ligne e
h 30 dans lieux bus de banlieue marche à
pied une heure et quart pour atteindre
mon collège de banlieue la même chose le
soir pour revenir le vendredi un autre
collège avec cette classe de 3e
d'affilée 1
vendredi après midi cette classe de 3e
la flûte à bec tous à cette classe de
troisième donc au bout de six mois je
craque ou trois semaines quand même il
ya une bataille à coups de chaises dans
ma classe donc je me rends compte qu'en
fait c'est un boulot d'éducateurs je ne
savais pas on n'avait pas dit et au bout
de six mois je commence à ne plus être
du tout copains et que la ratp avec tous
les retards et les soucis et puis les
métros bondés donc je choisi l'option de
y aller en voiture quitte à doubler ou
tripler le temps de trajet des fois sur
le retour les vendredis après midi sur
le périph
ça a le mérite par contre que quand vous
êtes vraiment au bout du rouleau vous
pouvez pleurer tranquillement dans la
voiture personne vous voit donc voilà
mes premières expériences de profs et
rapidement je me dis qu'il ya peut-être
un petit souci d'orientation
j'ai 24 ans et à ce moment là je ne sais
vraiment pas ce que je voudrais faire
quand je serai grand déjà la cuisine
commence à me titiller je me sens
quelques années que je me suis un petit
peu découvert cette passion et je
commence à me dire que ça pourrait être
sympa mais je suis pas capable à ce
moment-là de balayer cinq ans d'études
supérieures pour faire autre chose
j'avais vraiment l'impression d'avoir ça
aurait été une perte de temps c'est
assez compliqué quand vous êtes six
jeunes face à un problème d'orientation
je me retrouve un peu sauvé avec un
sursis en recevant un mail de
l'inspecteur de musique de mon académie
qui recrutent un professeur d'éducation
musicale pour la rentrée suivante sur un
poste à profil très très particulier
pour l'ouverture de ce qu'on a appelé à
l'époque un un tas d'excellence qui
était un projet monté par lui l'ancien
recteur de l'académie de créteil qui
s'appelle jean-michel blanquer
peut-être que vous voyez qui s'est
aujourd'hui et donc il y avait ce projet
très très très ambitieux de monter un
internat vraiment avec des projets
éducatifs très très poussée pour des
jeunes de banlieue parisienne et le
poste de prof de musique était le graal
cette espèce de postes improbable où
vous aviez des moyens illimités humains
matériels un partenariat avec l'opéra de
paris
des projets culturels un truc incroyable
alors là toujours les mêmes qui vous
déconseillé de passer le concours vous
dise non mais c'est pas la peine il faut
est agrégé faut être connu des
inspections pour postuler j'avais 15 ans
d'expérience tzr en seine-saint-denis
donc dans la balance y avait pas grand
chose mais j'étais je pense autant
motivés qu'eux en détresse
ce boulot qui me plaisait pas et du coup
du coup j'ai postulé j'ai passé les
entretiens et mon prix ils m'ont pris
avec très peu d'expérience mais je pense
que j'ai dû voilà j'ai dû apparemment
faire la différence
et là j'ai passé trois années
exceptionnelles trois années
exceptionnelles
professionnellement humainement des
rencontres avec d'autres professeurs
vraiment extraordinaire qui
s'investissaient sur un projet vraiment
très très motivant très très inspirant
des élèves qui pour certains d'ailleurs
sont peut-être passés par cette école
parce qu'on a on a vraiment envoyer des
enfants et des jeunes vers des filières
d'excellence et puis c'était à la fois
génial mais en même temps vous avez en
trois ans la possibilté de coché toutes
les cases que vous pouvez vouloir cocher
dans votre carrière d'éducation musicale
de professeur d'éducation musicale et je
me suis dit que de toute façon il
fallait que je fasse autre chose après
parce que je ne voyais pas à l'issue de
ces trois ans je m'étais donné retourner
dans un dans un collège lambda ce
n'était pas possible
à cette époque là il se passe une chose
dans ma vie privée qui tombe au bon
moment c'est que ma compagne passe le
concours de la magistrature et est prise
et du coup l'école est à bordeaux et
elle devait partir pour plus d'un an en
formation initiale à bordeaux et du coup
moi je me voyais pas du tout
je ne voyais pas dans la possibilité de
plus dans le noir tout va bien c'est
plus sympa je vous vois comme ça c'est
mieux
à ce moment là je me vois pas dans la
possibilité d'être séparé d'elle donc je
décide de prendre ce qu'on appelle une
disponibilité c'est à dire c'est à dire
d'arrêter d'enseigner et là je le décide
de m'inscrire pour passer un cap2
cuisinier vraiment samedi puis des
années et au final quelques semaines
avant ça je regardais masterchef à la
télé sur tf1
parce que ben j'aime bien la cuisine où
je regardais les trucs de cuisine à la
télé et je vois à la fin de la saison 3
casting ouvert
c'était la saison de pardon à la fin de
la saison 2 j'en parle à ma compagne je
dis tu en penses quoi du brésil
c'est pas très grave enfin toute façon
il ya vingt-quatre mille candidats
c'était le 24 mille candidats donc je
remplis ce petit questionnaire et puis
on est en novembre 2011
bon voilà j'oublie presque l'avoir fait
et là je suis en février 2012 quatre
mois après à la photocopieuse à
l'internât je reçois un coup de fil je
décroche
salut pierre ans et raphaël de shine
production pourtant d'inscription à
masterchef
alors il parle comme ça et tu te tutoie
c'est très bizarre ce qu'on appelait
monsieur lefebvre à l'internât on vous
voyait et tout d'un coup j'ai qu'est ce
qui se passe et est donc le type me pose
des questions me demande si je sais
faire une crème anglaise
des trucs un peu improbable et je suis
en train de dire mais oui c'est vrai
j'ai postulé à masterchef
je joue le jeu je le dis à personne sauf
à ma compagne et puis le casting dur je
remporte les étapes qui se succèdent et
puis je me retrouve à présenter un plat
devant le jury qu'on voit à la télé et
ils me disent oui c'est un samedi et du
coup le lundi je vais commencer le
tournage de masterchef
j'appelle en catastrophe mon proviseur
adjoint qui forcément je n'avais rien
dit et je lui dit écoute je vais pas
pour être avec les élèves lundi parce
que je me suis inscrit en master chef
et mon prix et mais attend rassure toi
il s'appelle régis assurera surpoids
régis il ya 100 candidats ils vont en
virée 20 jours donc je commence le lundi
il est un peu en panique pour me faire
remplacer et je sors de ce tournage
trois mois après en finale après être
passé par le désert du sahara pour faire
un tas jean cuisiner au pied des chutes
du niagara dans un palace à monaco sur
une plage en corse
je vais pas m'étendre sur le sujet ce
sinon je vais prendre tous les temps de
parole des autres speaker et il ya des
replays pour ça si vous voulez voir un
peu à quoi ça ressemblait mais forcément
ça change une vie
ça change une vie et ça mais aussi la
charrue avant les boeufs parce que
qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya des
millions téléspectateurs qui se met à
vous connaître
moi j'avais ce projet de changer de vie
pour la cuisine mais ça a été un
accélérateur de particules et les gens
vous prennent pour un grand chef
sauf que moi j'étais juste un prof de
musique passionnée par la cuisine qui
avait réussi d'aller aussi loin dans ce
concours de cuisine mais j'étais pas un
corps professionnel
donc ça m'a d'autant plus convaincu que
j'avais ce besoin de prendre le temps de
me former de faire ce fameux c ap que
j'ai fait en effectuant des stages dans
la région de bordeaux qui était très
important pour moi mais j'ai aussi dû
refuser des opportunités très
alléchantes des places dans des
structures d'exception qu'on proposait
en tant que chef mais je savais à ce
moment là de ma carrière que je n'étais
pas encore prêt que je n'avais pas cette
crédibilité j attaché beaucoup
d'importance
je me rappelle quand j'étais plusieurs
années auparavant en train de regarder
la nouvelle star à la télé ou ce genre
de choses
en tant que musicien de formation de
conservatoire je voyais les gens qui
pensaient devenir chanteur ans 3 mois et
6 mai à temps
détends toi faut faire dix ans de
conservatoire pour être musicien donc je
compte voilà pour moi c'était pas
possible de devenir cuisinier grâce à la
télé donc j'ai passé mon ca paix et à 27
ans je suis devenu cuisinier
beaucoup de gens me demandaient comment
tu peux passer de la musique à la
cuisine finalement j'y ai trouvé
beaucoup de points communs
déjà c'est un travail manuel un travail
d'expression
un travail de sensations on doit
apprendre un vocabulaire un langage
c'est nécessaire de passer par des
classiques avant de pouvoir improviser
tout le monde mange tout le monde écoute
de la musique c'est quelque chose qui
nous identifient et c'est ce qui fait
que la rencontre avec l'autre ou le
voyage est enrichissant mais la cuisine
et la musique sont aussi des médias on
peut véhiculer des idées des engagements
même faire de la politique je pense à
jimi hendrix sur la scène de woodstock
qui joue l'hymne américain en pleine
guerre du vietnam et qui fait entendre
des bruits de bombe avec sa guitare
électrique ou alors un cuisinier engagé
que j'essaie d'être moi au quotidien
dans mon restaurant qui va travailler de
façon vertueuse des légumes issus de
l'agriculture bio en circuit court de la
pêche durable d'essayer de proposer à la
carte des vins des vins sans chimie avec
peu de sulfites
il ya aussi au delà de ça cette idée de
fulgurances le jazz joué sans partition
cuisiner sans recette l'émotion d'un
instant l'expression d'un moment cette
idée d'art éphémère peut-être un parfait
mais je pense à miles davis qui compose
la musique d'ascenseur pour l'échafaud
en temps réel en découvrant le film avec
ses musiciens ou un grand chef alain
passard peut-être que vous le connaissez
qui a révolutionné la cuisine
gastronomique en remettant le légume une
betterave qui sort du potager au centre
de l'assiette bouger les lignes
bousculé les codes est ce que c'est de
l'imperfection
est-ce que la perfection c'est
l'assiette parfaite le plat signature
souvent les guides aujourd'hui jusqu'au
toit les guides ou les journalistes le
guide michelin vous demande quel est
votre plat signature
je n'ai pas de plats signatures pour moi
un plat qui est fini qu'on ne touche
plus et qu'on reproduit à l'infini
je ne vois pas vraiment quel peut être
l'intérêt c'est déjà obsolète
ce qui me plaît dans l'idée du voyage
c'est pas la destination mais le voyage
justement le parcours l'idée d'aller
dans la recherche de quelque chose
d'être dans l'expression de la saison du
terroir est-ce que après des oeuvres
d'art comme celle de mozart de bocuse on
est à lyon ou de vinci est ce qu'on doit
s'arrêter ou est-ce qu'on peut encore
continuer à chercher donc à 27 ans
devient cuisinier il m'arrive plein de
belles choses j'ai écrit des bouquins je
rencontre plein de gens je me forme et à
29 ans j'ouvre mon restaurant à caen
l'accolade
j'ai sept collaborateurs beaucoup de
jeunes en formation
quand j'ai commencé je n'avais que très
peu d'expérience en cuisine est
absolument aucune en management et en
gestion
donc j'ai fait plein de conneries
beaucoup et j'en ferai d'autres c'est
sûr mais j'ai la fierté d'avoir
rassemblé autour de moi une équipe en
quête d'un projet d'excellence c'est à
dire la simple idée d'essayer de faire
de son mieux ça prend du temps beaucoup
de temps et on apprend à en accorder
quand j'avais 20 ans de près votre âge
pour certains j'ai accordé beaucoup
d'importance au temps qui passe
vous imaginez l'idée d'un redoublement
ou d'une réorientation comme un échec
passé trente ans on change de
référentiels j'ai deux enfants et c'est
amusant comme le temps va de plus en
vite
à mon âge et en même temps on a vraiment
la capacité de 100 accordé
qu'est ce que la perfection est ce que
ces virages dans ma carrière sont de
l'imperfection d'un point de vue
peut-être moi je vois plutôt les choses
comme une succession de petits moments
parfaits mon premier concert après les
répétitions de led zeppelin dans le
garage le passage du capes la
transmission à des élèves la rencontre
amoureuse
masterchef une épreuve avec joël
robuchon l'ouverture d'un restaurant ou
bien sûr la naissance de mes enfants
alors certains vous diront oui mais il
ya perdu du temps les réorientations en
voir le verre à moitié vide les couches
à changer les nuits sans sommeil toute
situation a ses inconvénients
je pense que l'idée d'une vie peut être
parfait tous d'une quête
d'épanouissement personnel c'est d'être
à l'écouté de son environnement et de
rechercher sa vérité d'entreprendre dosé
de se tromper de se questionner et pour
ma part je sais pas encore ce que je
voudrais faire quand je serai grand
[Applaudissements]